socialist Bernie Sanders under fire
during last night's debate over his love
affair with Fidel what I said is what
Barack Obama said in terms of Cuba that
Cuba made progress on education yes I
think really really dictatorships
whether it is the Chinese or the Cubans
do something good you acknowledge that
that was just the start of Bernie's
problems the Democratic frontrunner
getting hit from all sides imagine
spending the better part of 2020 with
Bernie Sanders versus Donald Trump have
someone in charge of this ticket who
wants to put forward 60 trillion dollars
in spending three times the American
economy I don't think we do you talk
about what we're talking about with
Bernie Bernie in fact hasn't passed much
of anything I dug in I did the work and
then Bernie's team trashed me for it
Bernie's Bernie Bernie Bernie Bernie
Sanders I'm hearing my name mentioned a
little bit tonight all right so he got
the front runner treatment last night
Dana I just I don't think the attacks
are sharp enough and and they bleed him
out I think he survives also why are
they just doing it now yeah they will
Bernie Sanders has had these positions
for so long and they waited until he's
already amassed a delegates and he's got
a foothold in the race and he's
basically saying I know I'll have you
are attacking me 33 times compared to
Bloomberg 17 in this debate because I
have the leg up but all of those attacks
that are coming from within his own
party are not going to look very good in
general election ads that president
Trump's team will run against Bernie
Sanders and the fact that Bernie isn't
going to change his mind I mean maybe
that works with Bernie I will say this I
do think that his team has a much better
campaign than the Hillary Clinton team I
think they're super they're organized
they're quick they're kind of funny
they're everywhere did you see what
they're doing in Minnesota going right
in a clover chars backyard right before
Super Tuesday with a band I didn't
recognize the night shifts or something
or some
they like that anyway I know I'm
certified I'm gonna find the band for
you and tell you but basically he's
there they're super aggressive and
they're smart and I think that these
things won't look good in a general
election ad but I don't think it hurts
him in the primary Greg to explain to me
why Bernie feels the need to say good
things about bad people well you know
it's like like he was kind of half right
on Cuba Cuba didn't make improvements in
education they made improvements in
re-education they got a little confused
and then when they asked him how he was
gonna pay for his stuff he said how much
time do you have
so he couldn't even do it then but the
scary part about for the dams despite
all that he's still their best speaker
when he's up there he knows how to shut
people up by Goodson throat he gets up
there he starts talking and then he's
not gonna let the sentence in and he
keeps going and he keeps going and
meanwhile you have Buda Jets doing the
under talk well Here I am over here you
know actually molecules and I'm relaxed
and I'm confident and that's and I see
that I go Bernie is really good he out
of there he might be the most vulnerable
against Trump on the debate stage yeah
maybe
what do you think wand I think Trump
would chew him up alive I mean that
juror booth
Bernie Sanders one on one Bernie has
never really had to defend these crazy
positions one on one well I think that's
what he's done it's like a field of
seven or eight and Trump zeroing in I
think he would you know what if you
remember the line you know if you wanted
who's the real socialist the guy who's
giving money to the rich you know I mean
there'd be pretty strong so I don't
think that that's the problem I think
the problem is and this is something
that we have discussed them maybe
they're watching the five which is that
left-wing people in general are too open
to folks like Castro or the kind of
liberation movements in Latin America or
Northern Ireland the palace a do it
they're always gonna somehow say you
know what this is the resistance we
understand you're up against the man the
big corporate interest American military
power and the problem is that they did
so often these movements turned out to
be not good people and I can tell you
from my family history people who
oppress and who are discriminative
and then you know like the you know the
Sandinistas you say oh my god how do we
get involved with them I what the other
day we were talking about the woman in
what's what Asian country who's now you
know going at meat was it mere mart
going after them are me and Mari yeah
going after the the dissidents and the
minorities in her country and you know
they gave her the Nobel I was on sue
cheek there you go so I think that
there's a problem in that regard but my
point is I don't think Jesse that it
moves the needle for just for Bernie's
supporters I think if you're a guy in
York Pennsylvania and you say you know
what I can't pay my healthcare premium
in this country I can't with Castro sure
he's gonna solve that problem for me
you're my guy Bernie yeah okay the Cuba
utopia of health care and whatever else
they say is free and good and literacy
has been a staple of the left since the
Cuban Revolution I mean this is
something that they appraised it's been
indoctrinated in college classrooms for
decades that's nothing new but where
it's really gonna hurt Bernie in a
general election is the first thing his
taxes she's gonna raise taxes on every
single person in America which he admits
he's gonna take away your health
insurance the green new deal he supports
is going to cost an average family
seventy five thousand dollars just for
the first year which is double the
average of what an American family
actually makes in a year and then the
other thing is if Bernie Sanders were to
somehow win the White House which I
don't think that you should count them
out at this point because we don't know
the squad is going to be running
everything
AOC will be put in charge of something
all of her staffers will get positions
in the White House
Rashidah Talib will get a position
somewhere and all of her people will
come with her and be running the federal
position I don't know
but ill Haun Omar same thing she'll come
in be appointed to something someone
with a brother they could be maybe with
her brother yes is that you know this is
an entire restructuring of America that
ladies would skyrocket you convinced me
this would be amid terrible for the
country I'm over with